[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance is it possible Trump is
preparing to acknowledge that he and his
presidential campaign interacted with
the Russians before the election but
then to literally claim there was
nothing illegal about doing so the
Domesday defense something comes out
soon something definitive and not
arguable a leaked a recording an
indictment about collusion cooperation
coordination it doesn't matter what
something establishing as fact that
there was contact and unable to deny it
Trump will simply declare there is no
law against it the ability to turn on a
dime to contradict himself utterly and
completely and act as if he had always
believed that which he had denied an
hour ago is one of trumps few genuine
skills Russia I had nothing to do with
Russia oh that Russia of course we did
that with Russia so what it's not
illegal and he has already just done
something like this he's already done
something like this about Russia as if
just last week he would not accept that
the Russians had tried to interfere he
called it all of it a hoax but as soon
as he saw an opening by which you could
blame Barack Obama and by which he could
also get his own supporters to feel more
of the common sense of persecution that
sustains him and then he tweeted as fact
that the Russians had meddled in the
election and he used forms of the word
meddling five separate times in four
days that is the template for the
doomsday defense and the doomsday
defense simply is oh that sure he did
that but that's not illegal twice in
three days trump defenders have already
said this I never understood it anyway
said Trump's principal apologist Sean
Hannity on Friday the 23rd I know this
could apply to almost anything in life
Sean
conveniently then specified which thing
he never understood this time what was
the collusion that maybe somebody in the
Trump campaign talked to somebody in
Russia
because Russia's supposedly had the
information that Hillary Clinton had
destroyed on her server and that they
might say as the Trump campaign
representative wow you have that tell
the American people the truth let them
see it themselves release it is that a
crime to say release it to show the
truth to show damaging information well
yeah actually if you've asked the
Russian government to cyberattack
Americans or you're aware of Russian
espionage against America and you didn't
do anything to stop it
especially if this was done by them in
exchange for something yes that probably
would be a crime but that's not even the
point at the moment the point is that
Hannity described quote somebody in the
Trump campaign who talked to the
Russians and that they might say as a
trump campaign representative Wow you
have that Hannity has neither the
intelligence nor the imagination to have
dreamt up that phrasing by himself he is
floating a trial lead balloon two days
after that a former journalist Brit Hume
also tried it on Fox collusion well it
obviously would be alarming and highly
inappropriate for the Trump campaign of
which there is no evidence by the way of
colluding with the Russians it's not a
crime this is literally almost the same
thing as saying of course Trump's not
guilty but if he is as I noted at the
time this started a month ago with an
obscure Fox News host named Greg Jarrett
the last time Greg Jarrett had made
headlines it was when he was caught on
tape fighting cops at a Minnesota
Airport on the way back from rehab there
may have been a few bloggers who
preceded him but on May 23rd jarrett
seems to have been the first to
mainstream the perfect Fox defense of
course Trump never even conspired with
the Russians never ever but if he did
why it wouldn't be illegal week later he
went on the air with this collusion is
not a crime only an antitrust law you
can collude all you want with a foreign
government in an election there's no
such statute
his premise did not resonate Jarret is
technically correct Trump cannot be
charged with collusion he also cannot be
charged with contusion confusion or
conclusion they're not investigating him
for any of that the instructions from
the Justice Department to robert muller
were straightforward the special counsel
wrote Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein in his letter appointing
Muller is authorized to conduct the
investigation including any links and/or
coordination between the Russian
government and individuals associated
with the campaign of President Donald
Trump and any matters that arose or may
arise directly from the investigation as
PolitiFact noted no Muller can't charge
anybody for collusion but Trump and his
gang could be cited for fraud public
corruption conspiracy and soliciting
illegal foreign campaign contributions
that Muller reportedly may have reason
to investigate at 285 million dollar
deutsche bank loan to jared Kushner's
company while deutsche bank was being
investigated for allowing a russian
money-laundering scheme or the fact that
muller added to his team the head of the
do js criminal fraud division Andrew
Weissman adds a financial dimension to
the investigation against Trump and/or
his people particularly since Weissman
wants help to flip the Russian born
businessman felix seder and his mother
jones magazine so adroitly put it seder
went on to become a confidential
informant for the FBI and a trump
business partner now if there proves to
be evidence that there was more than
coordination between the campaign and
the russians like a quid pro quo for
policy changes favoring russia at
america's expense say then the possible
charges could be as serious as espionage
and treason but collusion now Trump is
absolutely positively not guilty of
collusion and even if his collusions not
illegal that's if he were guilty of it
which he's not never in a million years
but just in case they produce a tape of
him doing it while he's saying it's fun
to collude with Russians or there's a
confession from Michael Quinn or
something just remember trump is still
not guilty because it's not illegal and
he didn't do it and it's not a crime and
most of all he didn't ever do it and
even if he did
God resists peace